haremos un repaso rápido sobre
trigonometría y veremos aspectos de las
funciones trigonométricas que son
importantes para la ingeniería eléctrica
esta no va a ser una clase completa de
trigonometría y si ustedes nunca han
visto este tema antes los invito a que
vayan al portal de khan academy y
busquen los vídeos que tenemos sobre
trigonometría la forma en la que yo
recuerdo mis funciones trigonométricas
es con la frase sol s h
acá se h
y toca todas y esta es una frase de
mónico que uso para recordar mis
funciones trigonométricas dibujamos un
triángulo rectángulo así con un ángulo
theta acá ponemos etiquetas a los lados
del triángulo este es a porque ese lado
adyacente al ángulo este es el lado
opuesto a teta y por eso le ponemos una
o y este lado de acá es la hipotenusa
esta frase de acá nos dice que el cruce
no es igual al lado adyacente entre la
hipotenusa nos dice que el cose no
detecta es igual al lado adyacente entre
la hipotenusa y la última de aquí es
para la tangente que nos dice es igual
al lado opuesto entre el lado adyacente
opuesto entre adyacente y es por eso que
son todas nos ayuda a recordar nuestras
funciones trigonométricas
ahora dibujemos una línea aquí en este
círculo y vamos a hacer algunos cálculos
aquí tenemos la gráfica de un círculo
unitario lo que significa que el radio
de este círculo es 1 en cualquier parte
del círculo y lo que quiero saber es si
tengo aquí mi ángulo theta y recordemos
que los ángulos se miden a partir del
lado positivo del eje x del eje
horizontal este es mi eje x este es mi
eje y y los ángulos se miden en sentido
antihorario hablemos un momento sobre
cómo medimos los ángulos los ángulos se
miden de dos maneras una es usando
grados que va de 0 a 360 y los ángulos
también se miden en radiales que va de 0
a 2 pi
estas son dos maneras diferentes de
medir los ángulos y cuando medimos en
grados ponemos aquí una marca de grados
los radiales no tienen esta marca si
marcamos esto en grados aquí vamos a
tener cero grados aquí tendremos 90
grados
aquí 180 grados y aquí abajo 270 grados
y cuando regresamos al inicio
tendremos 360 grados si medimos los
mismos ángulos en radiales aquí
tendremos 0 radiales y cuando regrese
aquí voy a tener dos radiales si le doy
toda la vuelta al círculo voy a tener
dos radiales lo que significa que si
recorro la mitad del círculo aquí voy a
tener mi radiales la mitad de dos p y es
equivalente a 180 grados si recorre a
una cuarta parte del círculo es igual a
pi entre dos radiales y si recorro tres
cuartas partes del círculo voy a tener
tres medios de pi
o tres pi entre dos radiales vamos a
estar usando grados y radiales todo el
tiempo y vamos a pasar de uno a otro
constantemente ahora hagamos algunas
funciones trigonométricas con nuestro
ángulo theta en este círculo unitario
encontremos al seno coseno y tangente
aquí vamos a darle un nombre a esta
hipotenusa la vamos a llamar r y aquí r
siempre va a ser igual a 1 porque este
es el círculo unitario y por lo tanto r
siempre va a ser igual a 1 y para
dibujar nuestro triángulo rectángulo lo
que vamos a hacer es dibujar una línea
vertical a partir de aquí que sea
perpendicular al eje x y también vamos a
dibujar una línea horizontal a partir de
este punto que llegue perpendicularmente
al eje y esta sección del eje horizontal
aquí ese lado adyacente al ángulo teta y
esta distancia aquí del lado derecho del
triángulo va a ser nuestro lado opuesto
al ángulo
básicamente tendremos una intersección
en y aquí
y otra intersección en x acá estos
corresponden a números que van a
depender de la inclinación de esta línea
de aquí el seno de teta va a ser igual
veamos nuestra definición es igual al
lado opuesto entre la hipotenusa y aquí
en nuestro triángulo el lado opuesto
vale ya y la hipotenusa es r así que
esto es igual
entre r si vemos el coseno detecta este
va a ser igual según nuestra definición
al lado adyacente entre la hipotenusa el
lado adyacente es este valor de x entre
r que es nuestra hipotenusa y ahora la
tangente de teta según esta definición
es igual al lado opuesto entre el
adyacente y aquí el lado opuesto es y el
adyacente es x así que la tangente de
teta es igual a y entre x algo que
debemos notar sobre la tangente es que
es igual hay entre x o lo que es lo
mismo el desplazamiento vertical entre
el desplazamiento horizontal y s
es la pendiente la idea de la pendiente
y la de tangente están muy relacionadas
veamos un último tema cuanto es un
radial en grados puedo hacer esto usando
el análisis dimensional si tenemos 180
grados entre pi radiales
tendremos que un radial es igual a 180
grados entre p
y si escribimos esto en una calculadora
nos va a dar que es igual a 57.3 grados
aproximadamente por lo que un radial va
a estar un poco por arriba de 45 grados
más o menos por acá no lo usamos con
mucha frecuencia la mayor parte de las
veces cuando nos referimos a los
radiales es en términos de pin porque
tiene más sentido con este círculo pero
no está de más que ustedes sepan que
esto es aproximadamente un radial